this is Startalk I have a ton of
questions from GMOs and they are all
here's the weird thing and I don't know
they are all addressed to you they're
saying bill
dear mr. Nye dearest mr. Nye why are all
these people asking you about GMOs
here's here's the thing okay I wrote a
book a New York Times bestseller
undeniable evolution in the science of
creation yes
and in that book I had by the way it's a
great book I Love You Man by the way in
that board the point is or the thing of
it is in the book I have a chapter about
genetically modified organisms right and
at that time when I wrote it I said it's
always good to be cautious it's you
don't know what you're going to do to
the ecosystem but this led to a
controversy because turns out GMOs in my
opinion I spent some more time I met the
guy who won the World Food Prize okay
Rob Fraley won it's like the Nobel Prize
for farming for agriculture and he's in
my opinion really not such a bad guy and
he believes that we can raise more food
than ever on less land in other words we
have 7.2 almost 7.3 billion people on
earth today ok he believes or his
colleagues believe they can raise food
for 9 billion people on 2% less land
which is great that's a noble goal and
it's a noble and here's the thing that
happened in my opinion
Monsanto developed something called
glyphosate ok or rather a salt of
glyphosate this is a way to put this
chemical on to soil and have it stay
there pretty well ok anybody kills
everything that's green kills everything
by inhibiting the shikimate acid pathway
so you're literally salting the earth
yes yes however what Rob Fraley in these
several other guys who were working at
Monsanto they'd be hated Monsanto what
they did
is develop a gene that lets this yushik
emic acid pathway get completed in the
green plant anyway
gots and this is the so called Roundup
Ready soybean corn cotton was the first
one right and here's there's two things
now everybody is familiar with roundup
as a weed killer it does kill weeds it
kills any green plant any green plant
with a couple exceptions which are quite
relevant anyway
he he argues that glyphosate is really
not such a bad thing compared to all the
other herbicides glyphosate is pretty
benign which I've done research now and
I've decided that's true I've changed my
mind about genetically modified foods
that's the that's the top it's the top
line you've changed your mind about
seeds so I looked into it there's no
difference between allergies among GMO
eaters and non GMO eaters there is a big
difference in inputs from an
agricultural standpoint organic farming
takes a lot more water takes a lot more
tillage yes it ends actually you end up
with less diversity of microbes in the
soil with a modern Roundup Ready crops
because you don't have to till you have
to turn the soil over to kill the weeds
right however there is a notorious weed
called Pig weed which is every bit as
friendly as it sounds ok and is it as
religious as bacon actually they used to
we people used to eat it eat the leaves
of Iran 'thus plants uh-huh but now it's
considered a weed because it's you have
to go to a lot of trouble to get the
food worth out of it got you and it has
a redundant gene now in other words it
has evolved over the last couple decades
okay so that it has amplified the gene
that makes this you can make it acid and
so a roundup doesn't kill can't kill it
yeah so you have a roundup resistant
weed now what you got so right now they
control what the adverb is mechanically
they tear it up they dig it out yeah and
these guys that they all passionately
that's right
these the farmers at Monsanto and
pioneer and DuPont they all tell stories
these are seed companies
they all tell stories when they were
kids they were farmers they dug up weeds
right and it was not really the good old
days so I've changed my mind about
genetically modified organisms and
that's why these things have come in I
mean I would have a claim Chuck that I
went about it in the scientific fashion
this is Startalk